ah le dcau finement le retour à la vie
active de nouveau le petit aller-retour
quotidiens vers son lieu de travail ou
son école et pour pas mal de gens c'est
aller retour il se fait via la route en
voiture ou en nous et tout est comme
avant sur la route les mêmes erreurs
sont commises
ça y est le jour on parle un peu voiture
moto route conduite est arrivé c'est
beau mais aujourd'hui sachez tout
d'abord qu'il ya deux ans je n'avais pas
encore le permis voiture pourquoi parce
que je suis sur paris et que moi j'ai
toujours fait du deux roues
j'ai d'abord eu une trottinette puis une
trottinette électrique
ensuite j'ai passer le bsr et j'ai
acheté un city stars de chez peugeot qui
est le scooter par excellence et ça je
veux rien entendre de ce qu'ils peuvent
pas conduire autre chose car 50
centimètres cubes dont qui ont que le
bsr mais qui veulent faire genre qui
conduisait un gros truc tous ceux qui
louent vous et ensuite j'ai découvert
que j'adorais de foule le deux roues et
du coup j'ai passé le permis moto et
voilà bref l'élément perturbateur de ça
c'est natsu comment tu fais pour aller à
un endroit avec ton chien en deux roues
battu peu mais c'est pas pratique
et aussi c'est dangereux genre si tu es
un accident tourner animal c'est chao et
je les fais plusieurs fois avec natsu
tout début quand je venais d'avoir il
était dans un sac à dos dans mon dos je
n'ai sûrement scouts mais j'étais pas
serein je n'étais pas serein je
comprends l'angoissé que les parents ont
vis-à-vis de leurs enfants et pourquoi
des enfants deviennent des enfants rois
j'ai c'est que mon chien bref j'ai donc
dû passer le permis voiture il ya deux
ans après cinq ans de deux roues et mec
je suis je suis nul en continu de
voitures laissées genre honteux de
malades
en fait j'étais habitué à un truc et sur
deux roues pendant des années et du coup
arriver dans un truc qui est beaucoup
plus long beaucoup plus large et dans
lequel n'était pas au centre met à
l'avant gauche bah je suis perdu
rassurez vous j'ai quand même eu le
permis parce que ayant perdu moto bassam
a beaucoup facilité dans tout ce qui est
passages de rapports de vitesse et to
warn up on a cette discussion je suis
choqué bref j'avais des facilités sur
plein de trucs mais aussi des lacunes
sur d'autres parce que bah ça se
contrôle pas du tout de la même manière
et j'ai un peu galéré je vais pas vous
mentir et bien évidemment la troisième
fois que je suis sorti de mon parking
j'ai raclé un photo comme jamais et j'ai
explosé la portière c'est bon voila mon
histoire personnelle avec la voiture de
roaillan chez qu'il ya de moins en moins
de gens qui passent le permis mais moi
j'ai plein de potes même cyprien un pâle
permis gotaga n'a pas le permis bref
j'ai plein potomac ont pas permis parce
que ça leur sert à rien et je vous avoue
que si j'avais pas de chien moi même
j'aurais pas passer le permis voiture
parce que rien ne m'aurait motivé à le
passer et que natsuki avait ce pouvoir
pour ceux qui prennent la route vous
savez à quel point c'est rageant je
crois que c'est l'endroit où il ya le
plus d'humains qui ragent hautmont
c'est pas devant les jeux vidéo c'est
faux c'est là que l'humain est le plus
de mauvaise foi le plus méchant le plus
violent où les gens viennent aux mains
et se frappent et surtout c'est là où
les gens se remettent le mois en
question
c'est sur la route bref lorraine nous a
fait une petite sélection de choses qui
sont passés sur la route qui va nous
faire du bien pour toutes les fois on a
failli avoir un accident parce qu'un
gars est inconscient et pas attentif à
ce qui l'entouré offrons-nous ce moment
d'apaisement soulageons nos coeurs
enragé par la route
cette attente a été longue j'avais
vraiment besoin d'en parler c'est grave
c'est une vidéo ce pas pour vous
divertir qu'on s'amuse c'est juste une
thérapie pour moi voilà je suis
gaulliste bref comme un saut à 150
km/heure bravo la vitesse sur une joie
octobre pas de visibilité âge est en
mode grand frère sam et parties des vie
où je regarde pour me dire à tout moment
il peut t'arriver une merde ne fait
jamais le fou lui car il roule à 150 km
heure alors qu'il est dans une montée ça
veut dire qu'il n'a pas de visibilité
sur ce qui arrive et ce qui arrive dans
la descente face à lui ses deux moteurs
côte à côte en train de doubler de
voiture alors qu'il ya une ligne blanche
rien ne va nous sommes d'accord oh la la
la la
[Musique]
ohlala j'aimerais voir là dans leur tête
ce qui se disent c'est ouf la chance
qu'ils ont été piqués de rappel à tous
section de route faisons pas les ouf
[ __ ] j'aurais dû être en dessous par
le gouvernement l'a pour la sécurité
routière on voit l'argent macro d'accord
les cyclistes je sais je sais que ça
vous arrive souvent de voir des deux
roues des voitures des camions de
livraison warning sur une piste cyclable
et ça vous fait chier et vous avez
raison
elles sont à vous ces pistes cyclables à
et souvent les gens qui vous volent vos
pistes cyclables il leur arrive rien ils
sont pas punis il n'y a pas d'amour n'ya
rien généralement et ben c'est une vidéo
là elle est pour vous on est donc à
londres il ya tout les embouteillages et
ya un cycliste qui a vu plusieurs fois
de mercedes met en danger du cycliste au
bape versé dans les bouchons qu'est ce
qu'elle fait hop là ça empruntent la
piste cyclable mais superman est là
il tend son doigt dans cette situation
on vous a pris la main dans le sac
c'est pas de chance vous vous remettez
en question où vous vouliez vous niez
l'infraction et vous embrouiller
superman le sexisme dimech tarn à faire
la retourne dans les embouteillages
come-back watts il le top avec ce foutu
gabba gabba innovateur beaucoup plus
fort brian duensing les gars s'il vous
plaît ne ressembl ait jamais ça
franchement j'ai plein de défauts mais
la mauvaise foi comme ça l'a poussé à ce
level ça m'échappe genre je comprends
pas comment c'est possible elle est
incroyable cette punch dont claudia
continue à faire le malin qu'est ce qui
va se passer alors tu vas faire le film
où les policiers
avec cette mauvaise foi le guen et sur
une piste cyclable voiture et il dit
c'est lui il s'arrête devant de la
voiture il bouge plus j'ai des amis en
créneau quand je vous dis que je suis
nul
cette vidéo elle est faite pour moi
c'est un camion qui a explosé une
voiture en voulant faire un manoeuvre
mais exploser ce cameraman et un immense
fdp
parce qu'au lieu de donner des
indications conducteur du camion et de
l'aider à faire sa manoeuvre déjà il
filme et se fout ta gueule et en plus le
conducteur du camion des panthers cette
voiture est garée sur une ligne d'un
stop et elle empêche par conséquent des
véhicules aux gros gabarits de tourner à
gauche dans cette vidéo des conducteurs
font face à une partie de la route qui a
été inondée à cause d'une forte forte +
option à vous trouver un moyen de
contourner l'eau option b vous avez
confiance à votre magnifique toyota
prius et en ses capacités de sous-marins
observé voyons alors je pense que caa a
capté que j'avais autant d'eau je suis
désolé je trouve ça à mourir de rire
je trouve ça si drôle mais ça n'est pas
le moteur qui se retrouve sous l'eau
comme ça tous les mécaniciens là vous
êtes en sueur actuellement où vous vous
trouvez que ça se tente bon à l'arrivée
voilà le conducteur se fait sauver son
sac à main et aider et tout le monde a
appris quelque chose ce jour-là une
toyota prius ne va pas dans l'eau un
autre truc sur lequel je rage beaucoup
moi c'est les jambes qui modifient leur
peau que ce soit voiture ou deux roues
et qui retient la chicane la chicane
c'est le truc qui fait que ça dépasse
pas un certain nombre de décibels le pot
d'échappement je comprends à la limite
ce délire si tu fais ce genre de
l'autoroute et que tu passes pas à des
endroits où il ya des gens qui vivent
mais les gens qui font ça en ville
franchement pas cool
dans cette vidéo on est à dubaï et il ya
un mec qu'elle lamborghini aventador je
sais pas s'il a loué ou si c'est la
sienne mais il s'amuse aux feux rouges
avaient rugi re son auteur sauf qu'il va
tellement le faire mais je sais pas
comment
la voiture a pris feu
il a pas l'air de voir qu'elle a pris
feu il a plus de lamborghini
désolé je suis vraiment un bâtard de
moquer de ça mais pourquoi faire mes
gars du bruit coller à des immeubles où
il ya des gens qui se trouvent se repose
je suis vieux je suis une vieille
personne oui prochaine vidéo j'ai vu ça
de mes propres yeux et c'est jouissif de
ouf on parle tous les districts ont lieu
sur la route et un truc aussi qui est
horrible c'est les gens qui prennent la
route pour une poubelle et qui balancent
leurs mégots leurs canettes leurs
bouteilles en plastique comme ça par la
fenêtre à 100 km heure ça c'est un truc
qui me rend fou parce que ça coûte
vraiment rien de le [ __ ] dans sa
portière et de le jeter dans une
poubelle
une fois arrivés à destination de bois
au plat lui la buse de vous mais
vraiment il abuse de il jette mille
trucs pas toi y'a hulk qui étaient dans
la voiture derrière lui c'est pas de
chance c'est chao tu jettes pâte et
rigueur fdp hulk est tellement imposant
que le gars est allé ramasser ce qui l'a
lancé faut qu'il devienne éducateurs ce
gars est un truc cool quand même à notre
époque c'est qu'on commence à être
éveillé sur pas mal de choses y compris
sur le fait de lancer ses déchets à
travers sa fenêtre les gens ne tolère
plus du tout genre de comportement parce
qu'il ya les mecs qui font ça non plus
aucune excuse et savent que c'est mal et
donc les gens se mettent à agir et à
leur dire mais qu'est ce que tu fais
c'est pas bien fait plus à bolloré
puisse passer du matériel shot avec l'un
des déchets mais il lui a dit mec
ramasse tes trucs telle merde c'est bien
un camion défense une voiture en
tournant et ne le remarque même pas
[Musique]
quelles sont de ma chance et ça ça ça
m'est arrivé avec un bus raconte ta vie
comme squeeze c'était ya quatre ans sur
une double voix via un bus qui à ma
gauche puis à droite est en fait le but
était sur la voie de gauche pour tourner
à droite parce que la manoeuvre
nécessité qu'il soit sur la voie de
gauche et ce conducteur de bus n'a pas
regardé son rétroviseur et n'a pas vu
que j'étais sur la droite du coup un
tournant il s'est rabattu sur moi et ça
fait tout drôle eux la moto est tombé
par terre
quelle fut ma surprise en allant toqués
en hurlant de rage à la porte de ce
quart de constater que c'était un quart
coulé et que l'entièreté des élèves
qu'ils contenaient était en train de me
filmer parce qu'il m'avait reconnu
croyez moi je suis parti alors le
constat est là elle est sûre snapshot
rôle ou la gueule qu'on a quand on
conduit c'est un truc de ouf
regardez ce front sage de sourcils il
fait ses petits contrôles et conduit
bien comment ça peut mal finir
qu'est ce qui a pu se passer
oui
[Musique]
on a une fait de la fête je vois si son
visage la compréhension vous allez bad
et tous les gens de rouge vous préviens
vous allez bad et c'est arrivé pas mal
de fois que sur la route à un pneu de
voiture se détache à une vitesse folle
et atterrissent dans la voiture ou le
deux roues de derrière il ya vraiment
des gens qui sont morts parce qu'ils
sont mangés un pneu de voiture sur la
route là franchement ils auraient pu se
passer ce à quoi le toit aurait pu
atterrir dans un dans un deux roues
voilées j'ai pas de chute
oh oh c'est génial assez génial personne
ne va le contest de tous les animaux
c'est le pire en buffalo mec j'en ai vu
au canada c'était c'est tellement beau
et majestueux mais jamais tu veux qu'on
te regarder jusqu'à la fin c'est une
masterpiece moi moi en voiture
sa part le russe je vais adorer c'est
sûr
je vais faire une démo de twitch deux
gammes au nom du coup tout le monde
s'impatiente et il va se passer que de
la merde
[Musique]
oh j'ai cru qu'elle accorde à voir
j'avais un pote pompiers qui m'avait dit
qu'en fait souvent dans les accidents de
voiture c'est ça qui est relou c'est le
risque d'un sur accident et dans
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de cas il ya
un sur accident lives of his work elle a
eu trois sur accident ils ont fait très
fort les russes toujours au top
un ouvrier qui explique que les dos
d'âne sont super efficace pour ralentir
les gens et en piste il y avait une mode
d'ailleurs de gens qui faisait ça sur ce
tapis s'amuser à prendre vis des dos
d'âne pour faire un jump et tous ces
supers dont je ne le fait pas un
connecteur rate une sortie et du coup il
ya deux trucs sur annonce ça me rend
triste je délaisse les crashs autoroutes
y sont hyper visuel et font très bad est
en fait assez un gars qui sera bamako
mais quel trou de balle j'essaie de ne
pas trop nerveux
restons calmes face à cette situation
vous restez calmes ou voulu insulter
mort fils de plus si t'es qu'une merde
qui sait pas les gps etc tu rates tu as
sorti tu prends ta faim osama très tendu
en fait il ya eu tellement d'accidents à
cause de ça à cause d'un mec qui rate sa
sortie et qui au dernier moment coupe la
voix tout le monde c'est terrible ça
c'est stop c'est terrible de dire tant
de fois c'est terrible sachez que si
vous voulez voir trop de vidéos comme ça
de gens qui savent pas conduire il ya un
seul aurait dit à un pour ça qu'ils
s'appellent idiote car etc et le plus
rageant ever là c'est pas du tout des
vidéos du cerveau dit là qu'on a regardé
mais voilà si vous avez une soif de ça
voilà vous devez allez messieurs dames
en cette séance vidéo nous allons tous
ensemble agir pour qu'il y ait moins dix
responsables sur les routes qui met en
danger d'autres personnes pour cela nous
allons tous ensemble
repassez nôtre est nécessaire un je vous
mets le lien description vous faites
tous nos tests moi je vais le faire la
main dans vite mais c'est long et c'est
long on va pas le faire ensemble si vous
avez faut à une réponse cetiom vous des
cours du lait pu pendant six mois c'est
parti oh non je me plein de choses mais
en fait moi même je fais partie de ceux
qui sont la source de ces choses écoutez
c'est la fin de cette vidéo
ça m'a fait très plaisir de parler avec
vous d'automobiles de moteurs depuis lé
de comportements irresponsables mais
aussi et avant tout nécessaire 1
prenez soin de vos sur la route rester
vigilant n'oubliez pas que c'est un
endroit très dangereux que nous soyons
en voiture ou en deux roues en vélo peu
importe ou même à pied même piétons
je vous fais de gros bisous mais fin de
vidéo c'est un mauvais message que tu
reçois le ta mère c'est fou ces gens
[Musique]
à